you made us a mixtape i love that it
just you come out like that right off
the top
and it's got that cassette player vibe
when i think about a mixtape like the
mistake i've made for people or that
they've made for me it's
it's like about a purpose you're
thinking of someone when you're making
it the songs in it all have a real
purpose there's a reason why you might
be trying to cheer someone up you might
be trying to tell someone that you love
them what was the vibe going into this
what were you trying to say to everybody
when you were like i'm making you a
mixtape and i'm putting all these songs
in it
yeah exactly what you just said like a
mixtape is something that's made out of
love from one person to another person
to say hey i'm thinking about you these
collections of songs here because i want
you to feel something and hopefully feel
good so yeah that's what it is
and it is it is a really feel good
collection of music like where was your
headspace at when you were
uh putting together these songs
oh probably in a terrible space
like the opposite
which is what made it such a brilliant
feat for me absolutely
in a terrible headspace but that's why
it was important for me to to make
that body of work then because i think
probably a lot of people really have
suffered in their own ways over the past
couple of years and um
you know i don't really think anybody
wanted to hear about my own mental
torture when we've all been going
through
you know everyone's had their own
personal things to to deal with big and
small
so yeah that's what was important for me
to make this because it's almost
you know was me
willing myself into
a happier space and it's worked i mean
today i feel great so
yeah it has it has worked because i feel
better and i hope that people that
listen to the mixtape can chill with
their friends now and
kind of just loosen up a little bit and
start to
you know shake off a little bit of the
past couple years
with any love is mute is music the thing
for you that always does that i know
that you you love moving as well and
your experience as a dancer
uh
is is part of it too but is music the
thing that really helps you the most go
from
say a bad head space
to a great headspace
yeah music and dance and art i mean
yeah anything creative really fashion
it all cheers me i mean everything stems
from music for me
but um
but there are lots of other like
important elements to
what i do that um
definitely really help
with my mood
we have a couple of um canadians that we
love on this as well daniel caesar and
the weekend when it comes to
collaborating with people what are you
looking for when you want to include
people in your work
i don't know like i guess like
i just normally into like a big ego you
know because i'm too like sensitive to
it so just people that are chill and
make it easy and fun and nice and just
not too like
hung up on like
their
i don't know yeah i guess their ego or
i just i like working with nice people
honestly i just i like working with nice
people and daniel caesar is so sweet and
so is able and shy girl
and and i've worked with a lot of people
on the mixtape that um
that have such wonderful personalities i
mean to be honest with you the main one
being al quincho who
who ep the record with me
and um he's just been so encouraging of
of my art and of me and
and of my voice and that's been
incredible collaborating with him just
because he's such a force of
constant inspiration and drive
and uh
happiness and good vibes
when the audience looks at um
an album from an artist and it's that
person's name on it and that person's
picture on it
maybe a lot of people don't look at the
collaborative process and all the people
that go into putting something together
what's cool about what you've been doing
is that sharing on your instagram when
you're talking about oh i'm making this
video or making this song
you make a point to like really
go into detail about
this person's contribution that person's
contribution
why is it so important for you to give
those people their shoutouts
um i think i've always been like that
i've always been very generous um
i don't know because it's just not a big
deal is it i think i'm very confident in
what i do i i really am confident
in the artist that i am and i'm really
confident in my contribution and i'm
confident in how hard i work and i'm
confident in how much i personally put
into it so it's like nothing to talk
about
what everyone else is doing too like
because we're all working at it and
that's that's saying isn't it if there's
like two candles and one candle lights
another candle like that candle doesn't
lose any flame they just both get flames
you know like yeah
candles don't like lose light you just
like keep on lying over and over again
so it's just
yeah it's not
it's not a big deal i find it like i
find it makes artists look insecure if
they're like like
you know if you look at someone's like
socials and they're just like saying
that they do everything all the time i
feel like it's like a sign of my
insecurity to be honest with you because
because it's not like even i feel very
competent creatively but i need so much
help
like i need so much help to get it done
and i need so much belief and
organization and filtering and
you know
distilling
constantly i need the people around me
to do that so i'm grateful to
to collaborate it makes my life easier
and it's more fun and it means i don't
have to be as neurotic
but even in the videos like you can see
it like you can feel the vibe from
watching the videos like i want to talk
about tears in the club because this one
is this video is everything
it has like all the things like on top
of the music being amazing
everyone's looks are amazing and the
choreography is just like
it's out of this world
as i was watching i was like this is one
of the most amazing things i've seen
as far as like a music video space goes
like i haven't felt this way watching a
music video in a very long time and i
think that is like one of the best
things i could say about uh
about a video
um but
you know the vision for it and the idea
behind it is that something is that you
going
waking up one day and going i see this
this this this and this and i want to
put this all in there
well tears like video is actually quite
a funny one because basically abel could
only shoot on one day
and i found out the day what that day
was about a week before
and i was in london and he was in l.a
and i had to fly to la and first like
exactly seven days before that video was
shot there was no director there was no
concept there were no outfits there were
no dancers there was no currency there
was nothing so i basically was like i
need to fly tomorrow then if we're
shooting in a week i need to fly and
even when i got on the plane there was
still no director
um i worked very closely with a
production company called objects and
animal they've been producing all of my
videos for like
i don't know well over a decade now
they're like sick of me
so like i landed now like there's this
director called amber um she's amazing
she's in new york she's up for it
she she said she'll fly in and do it so
i was like okay
amazing and amber and i got on the phone
and got on text and she started sending
me images we were talking about the
concept
and um
i was like i just wanted the dance scene
to look like this happening i was like i
didn't want it to be like a
choreography like routine i wanted to i
wanted it to tell the story of all the
different characters that you see in the
club and
and at the beginning it's like
it's like i'm like too drunk and i'm
trying to like get out of the club and
my friends are like no like we need to
go back in there like we've all had it
where we're out and it's never like me
or one of my friends and someone tries
to leave and it's like oh god like go
and get her like we're gonna pull her
back into like the club we're gonna like
sort her out we're gonna dance no we're
gonna have a good time so that was kind
of the feeling of it so i start out in
the rain and my friends come and they're
like pulling me back inside of the
madness which is my brain and the
emotions and this like hysteria that's
the club where where like um my lover is
and
and where i'm sort of experiencing
uh this this sort of like meltdown
um
but the dance scene i mean really we did
the choreography in two days
and
um
you know it was it was so incredible to
work with the
choreographers sean and zoe and all of
the dancers and
and it was tough you know but but i was
so lucky because you know how committed
all the dancers were considering we
literally had by the time we got our
like
ourselves together
we had two days pretty much to do
everything all of those lifts all of
those flips all of the choreography the
dancers i was just saying like some of
them especially the condem contemporary
dancers i was saying like they just wake
up every single day and they choose
violence for their bodies like they wake
up and they say like today i choose
violence and they go in that studio
and they rehearse over and over again
until they are black and blue and all of
the lifts were done by this amazing
dancer called bailey
and she took the brunt for me like while
we were doing all the workshopping she
was the one like workshopping being
thrown in the air and i was like no can
you do it like this so he's like hey can
you try it from this angle and bless her
by the end of it her arms were like
black and blue from being cool
and that's what i mean it takes a
village because
i couldn't have done that every single
time i couldn't have gone and
workshopped all of the lifts and been in
the music video and edited it and looked
good you know it's impossible so i
needed bailey like she was in the video
as well but i needed bailey to um
to
stand in for me so that i could
understand what was going on and so that
my body didn't get like
messed up you know too bad before the
shoot but
that's what being a dancer is and and
and i get it because i've been a dancer
as well you know i was a backing dancer
for many many many years um so i think i
love to treat my dancers like artists
because that's what they are and i love
i said to them i was like okay what
tricks can you do what do you want in
this if you could show one thing what
would it be you know and then i tried to
include all of those things in the edit
and then it was so good there was too
much stuff and captured like a dancer's
edit afterwards like another 60 seconds
have you seen the dancers edit there's
like another i haven't seen the dancers
edit now i'm gonna have to look for that
one too yeah there's a little like i
think it's about two minutes long maybe
just some really good cuts which didn't
make the video but i was like pam and
they were going for that needs to be in
the world as well so
i don't know what the question was but
yeah the dancers were great